[Music]
every fall they're dead leaves to rake
up
it's inevitable
from cells to stars
everything dies in the end
that's just the way things work
but here's the thing
our strange rock itself can also be
lethal
[Music]
you know up in space you're looking down
at earth and you go wow what a beautiful
spot that is down there that blue orb
out there in the distance
but i'll tell you it's an angry planet
we tend to think of earth as our life
support but it's not there to support us
at all
and as you look down on it
it's a place that's
violent that's beautiful that's crazy
that's
intense
mother nature is a serial killer
no one is better
eight astronauts with over a thousand
days in space between them can tell us
how being up there
helped them to truly understand what
goes on down here
we think we know our home
but here's the secret
we wouldn't be here without
mass suicide
fatal passions and an event so
devastating
it makes the extinction of the dinosaurs
look like a tea party
earth might be the weirdest place in the
whole universe
[Music]
you know i think every astronaut
understands that going to space is a
high risk endeavor and that your life is
on the line
i came to realize this more than most
when i spent five months living on
another world
the russian space station mir where
survival was a daily struggle
just want to give you a little tour of
mir on jerry linninger of course
mere mission eo22 would turn out to be
the longest five months of my life
back on earth sometimes i can close my
eyes and i can be back up there again
your go for shuttle ods hatch opening
for delta p under 0.2
we open the hatch of the old 13 euro mir
space station
and it's kind of like going down into
grandma's
cellar
stuffed with leftover equipment
garbage
i was really shocked
it took up the majority of our time just
trying to keep that thing going
when you're up there trying to use your
limited resources to stay alive
it finally sort of hit me as wow
survival instinct you know was a
powerful innate force within each of us
i had about a month on mir when i hear
that master alarm
going off blaring
warning panel just lit up like a
christmas tree fire warning lights low
voltage lights everything flashing smoke
lights
look down the length of the module and
coming out of a solid-fueled oxygen
canister
is a big flame
low torch-like intensity
two or three feet in length sparks
flying off the end of it
sparks flying everywhere
i have never seen smoke spread like it's
spread on that space station
so within about 30 seconds you know
can't see the five fingers in front of
your face
excited better get some oxygen while i
can
getting a little peripheral vision
blurring
finally locate the mass
breathe in and i get nothing
[Music]
people talk about that tunnel of death
the next 60 seconds or so in my life you
know it's frame by frame
first thought was in my family and never
seen him again
my baby son and i just yelled it out i
said goodbye john
you know i'm really sorry i'm letting
you down
at that point i was kind of okay
losing my life
[Music]
in the middle of all this flame and
smoke suddenly you know something
changed inside me
i said jerry you gotta get through this
and then i just scream out gonna get
that fire out gonna see my boy again
jerry you have to survive
i broke into action one fire
extinguisher a second fire extinguisher
a third fire extinguisher
somehow we managed to get the fire under
control
you know it's instant survive
[Music]
however much we struggle to survive
it's not only old age accident or injury
that can get you
earth can be deadly
it's hard to fathom but there have been
five mass extinctions on the planet
and 99.9
of all species that have ever lived are
gone
[Music]
252 million years ago
earth suddenly turned toxic to life
way before the dinosaurs
nearly 96 of species worldwide
rapidly became extinct
it's known as the great dying
the great dying
is an understatement
it all kicked off when a whole host of
super volcanoes erupted
the land dried out
and the oceans
acidified
nearly all plant life perished
and every forest on the planet died
earth turned into the biggest mass
murder scene in history
everything that lives today owes its
life to the survivors of the great dying
we're all descended from the ones that
scrape through
today we're searching an area of
prehistoric floodplain for evidence of a
creature that was an evolutionary
stepping stone towards mammals
find something
all over this area we've discovered
ancient tunnels
that have been naturally infilled and
then cast into the rock
it wasn't long before we started finding
bits of fossil bone and eventually we
found complete skeletons and those
skeletons all turned out to be a
mammalite reptile called throne accident
a good way to picture through an
accident is to think about the meerkat
but without fur and possibly laying eggs
like reptiles
but most importantly and similarly to
the meerkat it lived underground digging
burrows with its large claws
they were surviving by living
underground
to withstand the heat of the day and the
cold of the night
[Music]
one of the really very nice specimens
that we found here are two infant
trinaxidone curled up together head to
head
[Music]
they were sharing their body heat which
they brought down from the surface
underground which suggests that they
were beginning to regulate their
temperature
on their way to becoming warm blooded
and of course true mammals
so you can see if it had not been for
creatures like throne accident surviving
this great dying we humans might never
have evolved
[Music]
our ancestors weren't the biggest or the
baddest they just happened to sleep in
the dirt
luckily that was the safest place to be
you never know who's going to beat the
odds
throughout the history of life on earth
species have
risen and they've died off
over and over again
and now the earth is resplendent with
life you can't get away from life on
earth you dig a mile down into the rock
and there's still little things living
you go to the
hottest
jet in the center of
of the ocean where the boiling stuff is
pouring out of the world and it's a farm
of life down there
you know the diversity of living things
on earth ensures that life will go on no
matter what the earth throws at it no
matter which
punch it takes no matter which species
doesn't make it there's another one that
finds a pathway to survival
so it's a good thing that life comes in
a variety path but variety comes from
diversity and diversity comes from what
scientists call
doing it
if you're a clone you don't have to date
you want kids just copy yourself easy
but clones have a problem
if every individual is exactly the same
one disease one catastrophe could wipe
them all out
so
you gotta mix it up a little
[Music]
[Music]
this is musa
it's an underwater museum of art
[Music]
so
the sculptures are becoming home to
coral species
these animals are amazing
they can make identical clones of
themselves to spread over a reef
but they also protect themselves against
changing conditions by having sex
in a strange way
once a year
around the time of a full moon
[Music]
the girls release eggs and sperm
in massive numbers
as the eggs begin to float
it feels like you're floating on the
milky way
[Music]
the eggs join together with sperm cells
from other corals
by all mating like this at the same time
it increases the chances of mixing up
their genes
to create more diversity in the next
generation of corals
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's how most of these reef building
corals have survived in the
ever-changing ocean for 250 million
years
[Music]
you take two individuals and you mix all
the dna and you create a different
creature a different animal than the
original pair
every child or offspring is different
than the parent and this ensures
survivability of that species
you look at my own family i look at my
children oh my god they're just totally
different human beings
and hopefully better than me
[Music]
sex
so you may have all been doing it for
fun
but i'm in it for the survival of the
species
it's crucial to mix the gene pool and
life goes to great lengths to do that
[Music]
[Music]
mayfly nymphs remind me of aliens from a
sci-fi film
[Music]
they live and grow in the mud for a year
waiting for the right conditions to
emerge
once the mayfly nymphs are mature they
have to swim to the surface of the water
if they don't do this fast enough they
will be eaten by a fish
[Music]
what happens next is one of the
strangest life cycles on earth
it's like a fish turning into a bird in
just one day
the adults
can't eat they have no mouth parts they
have no digestive system
for an adult mayfly it's all about the
sex
and they have just 24 hours to find a
mate
and then they die
[Music]
[Music]
weirdly they're mating often coincides
with the 4th of july celebrations
the males in a swarm fly up and down
then the females fly by these males
and whichever males fast enough to catch
her is the one who gets to mate
once the mayflies have mated the males
are done
the females
find water and lay their eggs
and then they too
pass on
they only last 24 hours
it's amazing the lengths that life will
go to to reproduce
once sex came along it was no longer
enough to just survive
you had to attract a mate
and that's when life on earth learned to
dress
to impress
[Music]
sexual reproduction has made the earth
beautiful
[Music]
it's one of the greatest evolutionary
tools for a complex life on earth
[Music]
you know without sexual reproduction
life would not have the diversity that
it needs
that it absolutely needs to survive on
this very tough
demanding earth
[Music]
we might like it
we might need it
but doing the deed
comes with a price
the only thing for sure in life
you're gonna die
even if you don't get hit by an asteroid
or
eaten by a bear keeping something as
complicated as a human going takes a lot
of upkeep
as a physician i'm fascinated with the
whole human body and how it works
human body is incredible it's like 37
trillion cells
it's more than the stars in the galaxy
[Music]
but sitting here today i'm not the me
that i was up in space my cells have
cycled hundreds of thousands of cells a
day are dropping off of me
and so when you look at me this is not
the hand i had
back in space
right now there's hundreds of millions
of cells dying
within your body
and your body has to replace those
and it's the way we are able to stay
alive as a living being
[Music]
you know most of this destruction is
inside our body but out on our skin we
actually can see it it's much more
visible
it's kind of a harmless thing down here
on earth but up in space you know it's a
different matter
[Applause]
in microgravity everything floats
your dry skin is going to float in space
once a week we clean house all day
saturday
we go around with the vacuum cleaner and
clean
all of our dead skin which is collecting
on all of the surfaces of the filters
around the ship
if you pull your sock off a lot of skin
dead skin will go flying around
it doesn't just become something in your
sock but it becomes a floating cloud of
unused dead skin
and that's a really good day to have
taken off your sock right next to an air
intake so that you can just sort of turn
your head and then go get the vacuum
cleaner and vacuum up the sole of your
own foot
but the clock is always ticking
cells can only repair so many times
before there's a failure
each time a cell replicates small errors
creep in
and along with other wear and tear over
time this damage builds up
and when you have enough of that failure
when it accumulates
it's the end of life
that's why we die
making a new creature
can be easier than mending an old one
that's the best way to keep your genes
going
knowing that
doesn't make it any easier when the end
comes
[Music]
ready
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
be
[Music]
you know you really need death in order
to have this
complex world that we have
it sort of is the arbitrator
by having death you have new life
taking its place
and probably an improved form of that
life
[Music]
it's a pretty impressive fire yeah
that is unreal
that's probably ammo in that [ __ ] stay
away from there
every firefighter has a respect for fire
a fear for fire
as you start fighting that fire you're
right up close to it
the sound it's overwhelming
you can't see very well
your eyes are burning
your lungs are burning
it just doesn't care what it burns
vegetation
people's property
it's extremely unforgiving
[Music]
fires do kill
but you have to realize there is a sense
of health that does come from fires
after the fact
it burns dead trees and duff away on the
ground and it allows new things to grow
it is a part of nature and what it does
death is a necessary part of the cycle
of life
[Music]
mother nature kills
to regrow life
it's death that provides the window of
opportunity for new forms of life to
occur
[Music]
death life death life death life
and it helps to perpetuate things and
improve things on the planet
nature takes us all in the end but she
doesn't do it to be cruel
getting rid of the old makes way for the
new
on planet earth death is not the end
this is not a wasteful world
the dead feed the living
[Music]
[Music]
we all know it's a one-way trip when
salmon go to spawn
[Music]
no one knows that more than the cam
chadkins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every year to mark the return of the
fish they hold a dance to celebrate the
connection between life sex and death
[Music]
it's an endurance event
like the salmon they bop till they drop
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
the bears and the fishermen get a bounty
but they're not the only ones who feast
on the dead
you know earth is really just waiting
for you to drop dead so that it can
recycle you and use all your parts and
some other form of life
the salmon are packed with an element
that is essential for life and that's
nitrogen
[Music]
salmon die
and then the trees use the nitrogen as a
type of fertilizer the animal body
decomposing
being used by plants
the trees pick up the nitrogen
and they flourish
[Music]
those elements are now part of the
ecosystem and they
help out other parts of the ecosystem
[Music]
without the salmon you don't have the
forest
[Music]
everything benefits from this banquet of
nitrogen
living things on earth they are
interdependent on each other and they
are interwoven
[Music]
i think as an astronaut looking down at
earth you understand that this world is
interconnected
you know you realize this is one heck of
a system down there and you're just in
awe of it
we used to think the world was flat
we like to think about things in
straight lines birth life death period
but that's not
really how it works
you need to take that line and bend it
into a circle birth life death birth
life death
so what does that mean
for us
[Music]
dad passed away before i was launched
into space
but i'll tell you i was up on that
mirror space station and i could just
sense my dad's presence there
[Music]
and almost out of the corner of my eye
it's almost like i'm seeing him
and i was almost afraid to look because
i thought if i look he won't be there
but by not looking
just feeling his presence he's sort of
telling me you know he's proud he's glad
i made it
[Music]
it was sort of a
psychological support for me out there
and i had his presence there probably
you know four or five times near my time
and space when i needed it it was
something i could draw upon
[Music]
my father's time on this earth has come
to an end
but i find comfort in knowing that he
still lives on
because on our strange rock
nothing is ever truly gone
he is forever a part of
one
beautiful pattern of life
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
usually
foreign
you're just a speck in this long
timeline of life on earth
we don't really think of the string of
events that had to take place for us to
exist today
from the survivors of those mass
extinctions
to the cycles of death that keep the
planet so alive today
a million migrating salmon
a billion mating mayflies in the sky
mixing the genes and and all those
combinations and permutations
yet all those different things had to
weave together all those chance meetings
had to take place
grandparents coming over from the old
country that all had to happen
my father's life he had to survive world
war ii
you know his best friend jerry did not
survive that's why i'm jerry you know
named after my dad's best friend
if you look at a history book there's
nothing special about my dad he's not
going to be in there
but he influenced my life
and he was somebody who always told me
and be anything you set your mind to
and if you work hard and you study hard
for example jerry you'll be an astronaut
someday
and when you think of all those things
that had to happen to create the human
being called jerry linninger at that
moment who then becomes an astronaut
floating above the planet going 17
500 miles an hour a life dream
it's incredible
you know i had to meet my wife
we overlapped at a job by one day
you know would john jeff henry and grace
exist without that chance meeting
without
us getting together at the right time at
the right place in a beautiful
you know summer night
[Music]
i kind of feel that i've done my job now
my family has grown at this point and
i'm proud of them
and if i move on to you know another
life i'm kind of okay with that at this
point
[Music]
foreign
and i feel i'm going to keep going on
and on to my through my kids
so i hope
down the line
getting emotional here uh down the line
you know my sons my daughter draw upon
something that their dad did for them
you know what i how i influence them
[Music]
we're all
against all odds we are all against all
odds
you know our very
existence on earth against all odds and
so you know take advantage of it
make the most of it
next time
do we need to escape this one strange
rock
and what would happen if we did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you